good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock at least one river has burst its
banks homes have been evacuated and tens
of thousands are still without power as
storm franklin becomes the third named
storm to hit the uk in a week if you're
heading out to work this morning then
check first because of a number of train
operators have cancelled services and
are telling passengers not to travel
it's monday the 21st of february
and i'm live in county antrim where gale
force winds have prompted a risk to life
warding as ireland north and south takes
another hammering from another storm
more than 200 flood warnings are in
place around the uk also this morning
living with kovid the prime minister is
today expected to announce the end of
all remaining coronavirus restrictions
in england
[Music]
a last-ditch hope for diplomacy on
ukraine the white house confirms
president joe biden has agreed in
principle to a summit with president
vladimir putin we await word from the
kremlin
but america's most senior diplomat says
they believe russia has already decided
to invade ukraine as satellite imagery
shows more troops and armor massing at
the border
[Music]
i'm live at windsor castle as the queen
plans to keep working through covid as
bucky and palace say that she'll carry
out light duties this week
i didn't start sbtv to make money i
started sbtv because it was a passion
a pioneer who changed the landscape of
both music and media sbtv founder jamal
edwards dies at the age of 31.
also coming up on the program for you
whatever you're watching around the
world today we'll speak to this
nine-year-old who's had to learn to walk
again after suffering from long covid
and after gold and silver medals in
curling
isn't enough to make up for a
disappointing winter olympics we'll ask
the chair of uk sport dame catherine
granger
[Music]
good morning everybody the third named
storm in a week is battering the uk this
morning at least one river has burst its
banks thousands of homes without power
and train operators in many parts of the
country have cancelled services and are
telling travellers to stay at home the
worst of the weather is currently over
northern ireland let's find out more
should we david standing by for us at
port rush in county antrim good morning
david i'll shout so you can hear me
what's it like there
well you'll not be doing any sailing or
playing any golf on the north coast of
northern ireland this morning k storm
franklin hit the west coast of this
island late last night at one point
seven different counties in the republic
of ireland were subject to an orange
warning they were recording waves of 42
feet out in the atlantic and a wind
speed of around 87 miles per hour off
galway so needless to say that had a
significant impact on flights coming in
and out of shannon airport some were
grounded and others were diverted to
dublin now donny goal on the northwest
corner of the island was bearing the
brunt of the storm but it's now making
its way eastward across northern ireland
where an amber alert is in place meaning
there is still a risk to life uh the
police servers of northern ireland are
warning people it's going to be a very
difficult commute and it's a similar
picture really right across the united
kingdom
we've had some pictures from scotland
for example are droson harbour where the
waves are crashing right onto the
promenade fairly crossings from belfast
to scotland and from belfast to
liverpool have already been suspended
and of course england doesn't escape
this either there are two severe flood
warnings in place around manchester
field operatives
at the um didsbury flood base and have
also posted some pictures from there and
the environment agency is urging people
to follow all advice and to evacuate
immediately if they're asked to do so
the other big problem of course is
fallen trees with roads blocked right
across the uk and ireland those trees
would have been weakened by the two
previous storms and several of them have
now been uprooted the fire service in
the midlands says two people who had a
very lucky escape when the tree fell on
their car near southern park so as the
storm continues to really blow here in
county anthem the message is very simple
from the police service don't travel
unless you really have to and if you
must make a journey this morning do so
with extreme caution okay david keep
well keep safe thank you well this is
the latest warning from the met office
as you can see it covers most of the
country winds from storm franklin
bringing possible disruption first thing
before easing through the day
a mess office amber wind warning covers
parts of northern ireland uh until about
now actually where damaging 80 mile an
hour gusts are possible a yellow warning
covers more of the uk until lunchtime
where guests will widely uh reach oh i
don't know some 50 to 60 miles an hour
gusts i should say locally higher
ireland has similar
warnings train services across the
country set for another day of delays
and cancellations as well a number of
train operators across the uk telling
passengers not to travel today without
being very aware of what's going on
others urging only essential travel and
warning of further delays and
cancellations due to block lines from
storm franklin passengers are urged to
contact their local operator before
setting out
we'll have more on that
in fact the minister's with us so why
don't we put that to him along with lots
of other things paul scully hello good
to see you this morning thank you
three named storms in a week how worried
are we
well i think it's been extraordinary
hasn't it it's been an extraordinary
week um i was in glasgow on tuesday on
business and uh when storm dudley hit
and then obviously back in london
to enjoy storm eunice eunice and now
poor people in uh in in the north
especially around mersey where there's
flood warnings um in disbury and uh
northern areas uh that they are they're
getting a battering but the emergency
services are working incredibly hard to
make sure that those people who are off
supply for their energy have been put
back on again and they've done
remarkably well but uh but it's
important that people stay safe look at
the flood warnings and and get the best
advice uh something else i want to talk
to you about is covered of course and
we're told uh that the pm will relax
covered rules this week what's the
science behind that decision so the
prime minister is meeting the uh cabinet
this morning to just to look through and
get that balance right so we can see
that uh uh infections are coming down
quite rapidly the hospitalizations and
deaths are following as well they tend
to lag behind obviously the case numbers
but nonetheless you can see the trend
within that he'll be looking at the uh
the best advice possible but getting the
balance right because it's important
that we don't work
and live under gov government dictat for
a moment longer than as than as
necessary to allow the economy to
recover to allow people to get back to a
sense of normality whilst keeping people
safe clearly um will the changes come
into effect this week it's thursday
friday isn't it well that's that's for
the prime minister to announce later on
i mean the the regulations fall away um
in about three weeks time anyway uh 22nd
of march um brought it forward but the
but the prime minister will make his
announcement later on another that that
final decision hasn't been taken okay um
as of then it looks as so even if you
test positive for covid you can you
don't have to self-isolate legally
uh so that will be well again that
decision will be taken uh later on so
we'll see the guidance around that but
uh but there will be a point when uh
all of this is falling away and so it
will come back to employers and
employees to make those decisions for
themselves but we'll see the guidance
that comes out later if a member of your
team next week say if this comes into
effect thursday friday next week if a
member of your team test positive for
covid would you tell them to stay at
home or come to work i mean i would say
that
like any illness frankly any
transmissible illness that you would say
uh you would say stay at home i mean
that's that's that you know if you had a
um a flu or something like that you'd
normally expect people to uh uh to take
the view but it'll be down to themselves
or down to their employer
yeah that's the problem though isn't it
because you're a responsible employer
and you would say to your staff stay at
home and get well but if somebody's
working on a construction site or you
know an industry that is sensitive to
the number of staff that is there
they're going to feel under pressure to
go to work aren't they there there's
this and this is why we need to uh make
sure that we've got really good guidance
uh for for employees but as i say there
will be there comes a time uh when when
the pandemic moves to more of an endemic
approach to
to to covert in the same way flu and
other other other viruses um
are treated and that's what we've got to
get back to but it's a fine balance
clearly and that's why cabinets meeting
this morning to go through the science
to go through that balance and debate it
and then obviously the prime minister
come before parliament to make his
announcement i understand but as as a
government minister you know as a
responsible employer as of today you
would say to somebody if they test
positive for kovit probably they should
stay at home so that they don't spread
it well that's what the rules are i mean
as of today that's that that that is the
rules so we'll sit next week but we'll
see what happens because i don't even
know when the date is that the prime
minister is going to gonna never hear it
because the decision hasn't been well
then
well then we'll see what the guidance is
because as i say you can't just um
preempt what he's going to say um
because
because the because yeah but it depends
on the date because the you can see that
the case numbers are coming down quite
significantly and if they carry on that
same electorate trajectory by the time
you get to the 22nd of march anyway
there will be a comparatively low rate
we're also dealing with
a predominantly a variant that's a lot
milder than previous variants that
doesn't mean we can
uh be complacent because what we are
saying is that kovid hasn't gone away
we're talking about balance because
we're still living with covert yeah but
what about those that are most
vulnerable in our society i mean we know
of a 95 year old lady who lives in a
castle you know and every covered
restriction is taken to keep her safe
and she's still contracted she won't and
this will this one happen and she's
still working but she's working from
home she's working uh
in isolation and that's exactly what
we're talking about learning to live
with kovid there is there comes a point
at some time when we're able to do that
we're able to give as many people back
there their freedoms uh as possible
where as many people to go about their
business and including uh the um
allowing the economy to recover but that
can't be at the expense of um
of human life and human wellbeing but
we've got to get that balance absolutely
right but if you're pressured by your
employer to go to work and you feel that
you shouldn't do you think that you know
as an employee you have a right to say
no i i don't want to spread this virus
any more than it is so i'm going to stay
at home yeah i mean look every employer
has a um a statutory duty to their
employees uh that is the case whether
it's covid whether it's any other
disease or any other ailment um i would
encourage any employee that is in that
situation to approach acas to go on the
a guest website to to um
and to follow through complaints through
that way because
employers no matter what it is have a
statutory duty
interestingly the um the unions a lot
the big three unions front line doctors
uh all saying it's reckless uttar lunacy
and a super spread of free-for-all why
are they all wrong do you think i just
think it's it's it's a balance that i
was talking about and uh clearly the
unions uh and the other uh people that
you describe sit and it's you know they
have their balance in a different place
what we've always said is that we don't
want to have
uh
a moment longer than than we need to to
have government dictating how people run
their lives and what's the rationale
between about getting rid of free tests
because if we don't have free tests
people won't spend 35 quid on a box of
tests so we won't know if there are any
variants so what we're going to do is uh
either way we'll have a a level of
surveillance so we can check for uh
variants we can check to see what what's
going on but nonetheless you saw the
prime minister yesterday talking about
the fact that we can't continue
forevermore spending two billion pounds
a month on tests and if you think what
might that that two billion pounds might
go towards there's a lot of um other uh
backlogs in the nhs other illnesses in
the back uh and the nhs that that money
could otherwise go for so for every
person that's worried about um a test
there may be another person that's
worried about a cancer diagnosis we know
when the free tests are going uh again
no that's the prime minister will make
his statement later on talk to me about
what's happening with uh
ukraine are we closer or further away
from the invasion this morning than we
were yesterday well i'm not sure about
yesterday but there is the clear signs
that the um that there are um still um
troop movements on the border there's 7
000 more troops than uh than there were
um just a few days ago despite the
russians trying to signal the fact that
they were pulling away from the border
so there is a very very credible threat
and that's why
we've got to continue to be vigilant
we've got to continue to work with uh
ukraine and poland as as liz trust the
foreign secretary was doing uh just this
week um and it's important that vladimir
putin comes to the to
with that we engage in diplomatic um uh
approach to this because otherwise the
loss of life will be horrendous okay
i've seen some of these tanks with zed
written on the side do we know what that
is i don't know no i don't know either
lots of papers are reflecting on that
today i'm sure it'll become apparent
in the fullness of time
how much do we have to take our hat off
to the soft diplomacy from president
macron who again was on the phone
yesterday to president putin for almost
two hours and it does look as though we
might potentially be heading towards
some sort of summit between the
americans and the russians as a direct
result of president macron getting
involved i think what's really good is
that all of the nato countries are
working closely together on this so that
they're all
playing leading roles in making sure
that we can defuse the situation and
hopefully therefore
vladimir putin will step back from that
situation which as i say will be pretty
horrendous but he does seem to be doing
macron seems to be far more effective
than we are i would just wondered why
that was no i'm not sure that's i'm not
sure that's right i think our foreign
secretary was you know i mean she was
snobbed when she went to moscow that's
because she's saying things that aren't
really
palatable to uh to the russian foreign
minister he doesn't things he doesn't
want to hear so uh
with but i think the french are doing it
in a different way and getting much
further than we do well not necessarily
i mean i think you have to um say the
good with that you have to say the
things that they don't want to hear but
then you have to give people a way out
that's that's just diplomacy um that you
never cut their their their retreat and
i hope therefore
um both of those approaches that come
together alongside the foreign
secretary's um work with poland and
ukraine and the prime minister being in
the security conference in munich will
actually bear fruit and vladimir putin
will come to see
that it's right to step back we know
that we've moved brits out of the
embassy uh for now in kiev moved them
away to a different part of the country
we also know that the americans have
moved their embassy staff from moscow
for now what are we going to do
i'm i'm not privy to those conversations
as a i'm a business minister not foreign
office minister so you know quite a lot
about cyber attacks though don't you how
worried are we about cyber well yes i
mean that's a real that's a real threat
that's a real threat i mean we've
already seen
um uh a lot of work that's you know
they're worried about um cyber attacks
particularly in ukraine but that could
easily be a spread
further around europe and so these are
uh worried about how are we about them
in the uk well that we will be dealing
with those you know you know with with
the national cyber security center and
we're i'd push out um uh messages to any
business to make sure that they've got
um adequate protection whether it's
software and hardware
okay so we we haven't had any that we
need to worry about as of the last
couple of weeks when the attentions have
been heightened well there's nothing i
can i can report that you've been aware
of okay and before i let you go i wanted
to ask you a couple of things firstly
about um her majesty and um how do we
know how she is i i don't know but i
wish her um all the best i do understand
that she's um still working at home
and uh
and as we were talking earlier on about
about covid and what would happen if you
get it um it seems from what from the
reports i'm hearing that uh they're uh
relatively mild symptoms and i hope that
is exactly how it is until she's better
yeah as do we all 95 years young she
looks amazing still doesn't she tiny
tiny tiny put her in your pocket she's
amazing um just before we let you go
obviously the downing street party
question um if the pre-em gets a fixed
penalty notice
should he stay on
i think there's not much moved on to be
fair since last time i spoke to you i
think what we want to do is see what
happens with the police action and the
police report see what happens with the
sioux great report and then look at it
in the round uh what we've got to be
i've always said i've treated a real
high bar to get rid of any prime
minister what about if they break the
law because
i think we just need to see it in the
round that's why i want to see
i want to see
or and or um misguided parliament
misleads parliament
how can he stay well i think it
i need to see context i absolutely need
to see context before i make any any
decision and i think that's right
because uh
uh yeah but i understand this is i
understand this is one that's not
actually being investigated not by the
police the pictures that you would that
were not by the police so in terms of
law breaking that's not going to be um
that's not going to
reach the threshold of evidence but
nonetheless
that's what i mean about context that's
why i want to see the subway report see
what happens see what the police find
and then we can work through the um you
know have that conversation at that
point yeah but people singing happy
birthday in the cabinet room with your
interior designer there you know but
let's say that's what i want to see
you know i'm not gonna there's not a lot
i can add into a lot the the the the but
my question to start with was very
straightforward it wasn't about any of
the pictures that we're showing it was
about if the police have decided that
he's broken the law and he gets a fixed
penalty notice do we have a prime
minister in place who has broken the law
well i'm gonna i'm gonna wait until i
see context before i
you know really make any more judgment
on it it's good to talk to you thanks so
much indeed
thank you a quick look at what the
papers are doing the times leads with
the impending removal of final coverage
restrictions just talking about that
with the minister weren't we in england
highlighting what it calls the pride of
boris johnson in the move the guardian
has news that last ditch efforts to
avert a russian invasion of ukraine are
taking place
um that's led by uh president macron of
france more details of that have since
emerged overnight
the ft leads on the announcement that 30
000 russian troops will stay in belarus
indefinitely adding to western fears of
an invasion
and one keeps calm and carries on the
front page on the metro after the queen
tests positive for covert 19.
the white house says joe biden has
agreed in principle to meet the russian
president vladimir putin for a summit
over ukraine but recent satellite
imagery shows a new buildup of russian
troops and armoured vehicles on the
ukrainian border and the u.s says it
believes president putin has already
taken the decision to invade
hazi let's bring in deborah she's in
kiev um has been over the last couple of
weeks for us um morning to you debra
how does it feel where you are
well right now is the window that
western officials have been saying is
when they believed vladimir putin would
attack and so you can imagine that
people have been pretty um
thinking a lot about it there's not
panic in the streets but talking to
residents like no one's ignoring the
reality that you've got the president of
the united states who said very starkly
that he believed a decision had been
taken an advan an invasion would happen
it will happen this week and kiev would
be targeted but obviously unless and
until the troops start the tanks start
rolling and the airstrikes airstrikes
start falling there is still hope for
diplomacy and it is quite significant
what's been happening overnight like you
mentioned president biden were president
macron rather working the phones and
managing to
achieve potentially uh a summit between
president biden and president putin
we've heard from the white house haven't
we that they've said that
the u.s president has agreed in
principle to this we've yet to hear
anything from the kremlin and joe biden
has said that a summit would only happen
if an invasion doesn't happen
and we don't know details about any
summit either it's been described as
notional at the moment and something
that uh the us and the russian foreign
ministers uh would sort of hammer out
they've got a meeting planned on
thursday but all this diplomacy really
does hinge on an invasion not happening
and it's all taking place while in the
east of the country there is still that
escalation of fighting over the line of
contact between the russia-backed
separatists on one side ukrainian forces
on the other there's been this spike in
disinformation attempts according to
western officials to create a pretext
blamed on the ukrainian armed forces
that would give russia the excuse to
invade so still incredibly tense but
still a chance for a diplomatic draw
dial down okay thank you thanks a lot
queen's isolating at windsor this
morning after testing positive for covet
19. buckingham palace says the monarch
is experiencing mild symptoms and that
she hopes to keep carrying out what they
call light duties ally's there for us
this morning ali good morning good
morning um how's she doing
well she is resting here at windsor
castle and this is obviously the place k
where she spent so much of the pandemic
surrounded by hms bubble that small
group of royal household staff and there
was great effort taken of course to
protect the queen but as society has
opened up that has become more difficult
and we know that she has tested positive
but we also know
that she has had mild cold-like symptoms
and crucially that she will be carrying
on with light duties yesterday for
example soon after the news that she had
tested positive there was a message
posted on social media by the queen
congratulating the team gb curling team
so that's a sort of light duty i suspect
that we will see her carrying out over
the coming days she's going to be looked
after by the team of physicians here at
windsor castle she will be isolating she
is not someone who likes a fuss but i
think inevitably she is 95 years old
nearly 96 there is always an unease that
comes with any health issues that the
queen has so i think of course there
will be some concern and there have been
plenty of well-wishers wishing her the
best we know that she was told to rest
by doctors after spending a night in
hospital back in october we saw her
earlier this month marking the platinum
platinum julie sorry in
sandringham uh where she welcomed people
that was the biggest event that we had
seen her hold for a few months so that
was a significant
moment but i think she will want the
focus to stay on that remarkable 70
years that she has spent
on the throne she will want the focus to
be on the platinum jubilee and the royal
household um
saying that she has mild symptoms uh and
wanting i think really to get across a
message of reassurance that she will
carry on with work and that she will be
carrying out light duties over the next
few days
hello everybody our top stories for you
this morning listen up weather warnings
are in place across the uk as storm
franklin brings yet more torrential rain
and gale force winds
[Music]
the white house agrees in principle to a
summit with vladimir putin so long as
russia does not invade ukraine
and the prime minister prepares to
address parliament later on today
regarding his plans to remove england's
remaining coveted restrictions
[Music]
more on that now and the legal duty to
self-isolate could end later this week
when boris johnson lifts all remaining
covered restrictions earlier i asked the
business minister paul scully about the
announcement he told me the government
doesn't want to dictate how people live
their lives for longer than required
the prime minister is meeting the
cabinet this morning to just to look
through and get that balance right so we
can see that uh
infections are coming down quite rapidly
the hospitalizations and deaths are
following as well they tend to lag
behind obviously the case numbers but
nonetheless you can see the trend within
that he'll be looking at the uh the best
advice possible but getting the balance
right because it's important that we
don't work uh and live under gov
government dictat for a moment longer
than as than as necessary to allow the
economy to recover to allow people to
get back to a sense of normality whilst
keeping people safe clearly
tamara's here and he went on to say that
if your employer is forcing you to go to
work even though you feel that you might
have covered then there are options to
go to a cas i mean who's going to do
that yeah a lot of people aren't going
to do that i think you can get a sense
of the message that boris johnson's
going to be giving when he goes to
parliament this afternoon after agreeing
this plan with his cabinet this morning
he's going to be saying we can protect
ourselves without losing our freedom
this idea that government dictat as paul
scully put it mustn't last long
any moment longer than is necessary and
tory backbenchers are going to like that
a lot of them don't like the idea of the
government intervening in people's lives
to this extent but you can also see the
message that boris johnson is going to
be projecting to people at home who may
be thinking well hang on isn't this too
soon i don't want to be especially if
you're vulnerable walking around knowing
that there will be people with covid
potentially at your work or at your
child's school or just walking around
and so he's going to be saying look this
does not mean the pandemic is over
people should still be cautious if
you've got covert it's sensible if you
stay at home but the law is not going to
mandate you to i think what's going to
be more controversial and what i expect
members of the cabinet and mps this
afternoon to be asking questions about
is
should we be getting rid of testing then
because if people can't test they then
can't find out if they have covid and
we'll be interested to see what
exemptions are going to be put in place
this afternoon where testing is going to
be wound down but will key workers for
example get tests we haven't had an
answer to that yet i expect that there
will be something for the government to
announce on that boris johnson will be
telling everybody what the new rules are
this afternoon at a press conference we
expect the scientists to be with him be
looking out for whether their message is
the same as his message okay tomorrow's
take at nine o'clock looking forward to
it including what he said about
partygate be interesting to get your
take on that
before that though
let's uh bring you the very latest from
should we i i've just got my notes here
actually about dr salia ashan she's an
emergency medicine doctor currently
working in intensive care she's going to
be with us very shortly uh indeed before
that
let's get some more on our top story now
and the prime minister's expected to set
out how england will live with covey
today as downing street outlines the
lifting of all remaining restrictions um
let's bring in dr saleh ashan an
emergency medicine
doctor uh in just a moment but first
here's emma virtually in leicester um hi
emma uh update us on the situation there
well if you cast your mind back to the
summer of 2020 as the rest of us were
gearing up for our first
haircut for months and a chance to go
back to the pub or out for a meal here
in leicester they were facing the
toughest restrictions of all the first
place in the country to go into a local
lockdown
so as a
country today there will be literally
through what
just looking so the doctor wants to get
on air doesn't it here she is now an
emergency medicine doctor hello to
doctors sorry about the confusion thanks
for joining us on the program um this
morning how do you feel about these
restrictions being lifted probably by
the end of the week
i'm really nervous about that if i'm
brutally honest um i know we were about
to hear
about leicester being one of the first
areas in the uk to be plunged into quite
a harsh lockdown
what i don't want to see and i'm sure
what many other people don't want to see
is a flip-flop backwards and forwards
into you know uh hey guess what it's all
over we can go forth and live as normal
too then harsh lockdown because we've
let the virus out
it we know it's still mutating we were
lucky with omicron we we anticipated it
being a serious strain
that could cause many deaths we were
lucky this time it's not necessarily
going to be the same with the next
mutation and there will be a new
mutation i'm deeply concerned i'll be
super interested to hear what the
scientists are going to be saying lined
up with boris johnson today because
frankly we've not really heard from them
we have heard from boris i don't think
this is living with kovid i think this
is living with boris we've had him for
as long as we've had the pandemic
i was reflecting on that today we've had
to deal with both and the way that the
pandemic in the uk has been managed by
boris
i would not i welcome the
independent investigation that's going
to be an inquiry that's going to be
looking into his handling i'm concerned
pm is expected to tell mps that the
vaccine program testing and new
treatments that are available
including i think it's uh pallavid
one of the drugs that you can take if
you've got a coverage of your contracted
covid are all going to help keep the
public safe why is he wrong
i think this is throwing the baby out of
the bath water
we had a schedule that had been
carefully thought through a timing and a
time plan carefully thought through and
boris johnson has brought it forward by
about a month i'm not sure entirely well
we've still got a situation where we've
got one in 20 people
uh infected including her majesty the
queen with coved
why the rush i can't help but think with
boris johnson every decision that he
makes uh you've got to couple with is
this a political him a a political move
with him trying to say pc obviously we
know that majority have his toy
backbenchers are supportive of this plan
it really really muddies the water when
you're actually from from a scientific
and a healthcare perspective trying to
think of what's best for the nation not
what's best for politics
what i'm super super con this is the
scenario that i'm concerned about
imagine we already have about
73 000 people within the nhs who are not
vaccinated 30 000 of them
are exempt
if we get to a place and i know this is
still open to discussion but it is
important
if we have a place where people are not
required to test and they are not
required to stay at home should they be
ill
or even just be positive with copic not
even displaying signs and symptoms i'd
be very very concerned about
people coming in to work now a large
majority of people who work in the nhs
are agency staff they are not
under the same
restrictions as full-time employers
within the nhs they work through
agencies they do not have pensions they
do not have sick pay how are we going to
prevent people who are positive
with covid but we don't know
coming in to an environment where there
are sick vulnerable patients that is a
disaster we have to get it's been two
years we have to let the rest of the
country get back to normality eventually
don't we
i agree my gosh there is no one more i
i'm actually
off work at moment having a break
because the intensity of what we have
faced uh on the front line has been
immense
absolutely normality but
we our world has changed we've learned a
huge amount about coved and how to come
to this place where we are right now
where we are losing less and less people
it hasn't gone away there are measures
that we need to put in place to properly
live with covid we're talking about
proper ventilation in schools we're
talking about uh
measures to support people who are
unwell
with adequate sick pay we know that
there are 20 million people within the
uk right now who are not covered by sick
pay these are all the measures we need
to put in place to live with covered not
pretending that it doesn't exist because
it will unfortunately it's not me being
a crystal ball rose
scientifically we know that we will
possibly be having another strain
possibly uh
sorry
we have absolutely no guarantee on
knowing whether it would be less or more
virulent so with guarantee we know that
another mutation will come and what
we're actually doing now is helping that
along its way by throwing away all the
restrictions all in one go everyone go
forth and mix there was i was reading
about okay
i'm so sorry we've run out of time i'm
sorry you're going to go on to make
another point but hopefully we'll see
you again soon and we'll discuss it
further thank you thank you
thank you in other news the beijing
winter olympics has officially closed
with fake snow strict covered 19
restrictions and a doping scandal
hitting the headlines tom standing by in
beijing for the last time in a while on
this story although we've got the
paralympics to look forward to of course
um tom um
great britain didn't do as well as they
might have hoped how do uh china feel
that the games went more generally
morning k i think china will be really
happy with how it went um they saw it
off last night with another spectacular
ceremony they are good at that you'd
expect them to be able to control that
um but from the start these games have
been pretty controversial you mentioned
the fake snow it just doesn't snow here
in beijing we did get a bit of snowfall
but not nearly enough to host a winter
olympics there was that
camilla vellieva the russian teenager uh
who returned a positive test uh for a
sample taken before the olympics um that
still needs to be figured out because
she won team gold um at the start of the
games with the russian olympic committee
so what happens is that what happens to
the us and japan who are also uh who are
beaten by the russian olympic committee
and that will rumble on and then there
was the political side to all this there
was the diplomatic boycotts from the
west over what they say are human rights
abuses in china and china met those
criticisms head on it featured an
athlete from xinjiang as part of its
opening ceremony we had an official
recently say that everything was
happening in xinjiang was a lie when it
came to these allegations of forced
labor we also saw an appearance from
pong shui the olympian herself the
tennis player who had accused a
high-ranking chinese communist party
official of sexual assault she uh was
paraded apparently for the cameras so
there was a lot of controversy and then
the other bit of this was this was of
course a coveted olympics and i have to
say having been here you know the whole
time it hasn't felt like an olympic city
there are two separate beijings really
the olympic bubble and beijing the two
don't meet um so it hasn't been a lot of
fun it hasn't been very festive but it
has been very controlled and that's what
china likes okay thank you
take you back to ukraine now and
overnight the white house has confirmed
it has agreed in principle to a summit
with russia over the crisis so as long
as ukraine is not invaded the summit was
proposed by france's president macron
after two lengthy phone calls with
president putin yesterday joining us now
general lord richard dunn at the former
chief of the defence staff hello to my
lord thank you for joining us um again
we've been chatting quite a lot lately
where do you think we are compared to
the last time we chatted
well okay good morning um i think we can
take a crime of comfort from the
overnight news that uh president macron
um
interceding on behalf of the european
union because of course france holds the
presidency at the present moment we
appear to have achieved some conditional
agreement that there could be a summit
between president biden and
vladimir putin um on the important
condition that the russians don't invade
well i think we said all the way along
that uh talking is far better than
fighting so i think we should feel a
degree of encouragement about that but i
think
what vladimir putin really has to
remember we've said this so many times
kay is that
he's in pretty strong position on
putin's in quite a strong position while
he's got a large number of troops on the
border while he's threatening his
bullying he's intimidating people are
talking to him but if he crosses that
line if he attacks
in an unprovoked fashion
then he will go from someone people want
to talk to someone they absolutely don't
want to talk to uh russia will come
under huge sanctions come under huge
pressure and russia and putin will very
much go
into the category of of the paris of the
21st century
we know that russia has extended
military drills that were due to end
yesterday and how does that fit in
with diplomacy
well i think it's another tactic to to
keep the pressure on the west um
and i think the interesting thing is
apparently it was a very long phone
conversation between president macron
and vladimir putin
over the last 24 hours big question is
what were they talking about
we know that russia has put certain
demands on nato that
nato pulls back from other eastern
european countries well
nato's not going to do that um
the issue therefore turns on on ukraine
what position will
putin try and demand that the west takes
about ukraine i would imagine that what
he will want is an assurance that
ukraine will not
perhaps never join join nato um
in our previous conversations kay i said
that i personally think that is the
right thing that we should support
ukraine as an independent country but uh
thinking that ukraine could join nato
with the very special place that
russians feel about ukraine i think is a
provocation too far so it may well be
that the losers out of this uh are
ukraine or the ukrainians and their
aspiration to join nato but that doesn't
mean to say that we can't be on good
relations with ukraine uh from the west
good trading relations good defense
relations but that's very separate from
full-blooded membership of nato
what is it
what is he trying to achieve in your
opinion
by speaking a lot with the french almost
two hours yesterday on the phone with
president macron president macron's been
to moscow as well uh president schultz
um chancellor schultz has also been
to moscow and yet when the brits went
they were given short shrift divide and
rule
well of course um this is one of the
things that we've been saying right at
the outset that all the things that um
and the operations that uh vladimir
putin has mounted in recent years
from the annexation of crimea to a big
cyber attack on estonia
and other threatening moves that they've
made he wants to split the harmony of
the west split the harmony of nato so
saying one thing to one and one thing to
another uh is a
tactic in his mind whereby he can break
the
break the unity but um so far it's not
really been working for him because
against the possibility of a major armed
incursion invasion by russia of ukraine
the west is still speaking with one
voice but
if he extends the pressure if he extends
the period then other national interests
may well arise you mentioned germany
when germany is in a very difficult
position over the russian
gas pipeline issue um can germany really
afford to ditch the nordstrom 2
project but we don't think it can so by
keeping this going he is hoping to
promote splits in the west and
i think this is where western diplomats
the statesman i've got to be very
careful if they don't watch it there
will be no splits and he will become
even stronger
i don't know if you've seen your morning
papers yet a lot of them carrying
pictures of uh russian tanks with the
zed on the side um and the inference
from some is that that means that they
are battle ready have you ever seen that
before
well um it's it's a tactic well i'm not
attaching a procedure which we've used
in the past if you think back to the the
gulf war there was an inverted v on the
side of um
british and allied armored vehicles
which is really all part of battlefield
identification
i mean
no there's no getting away from it they
have made are making very full
preparations for a major armed incursion
um you know we've it's been reported
over recent days that all the
infrastructure the logistics the medical
support
is all there so there's no getting away
from the fact that the russians have
geared themselves up and are competing
to gear themselves up for a major
incursion but
i think the other thing okay which we've
got to watch is what's going on in
eastern ukraine this um business about
russian
citizens being helped to evacuate
because there is the threat of a
ukrainian offensive now this is so much
hogwash it looks very scripted but it's
the kind of circumstances which we may
find russia claiming and therefore
that's their justification to make a
major incursion as a counter-offensive
against the ukrainian offensive
personally i think it's rubbish i think
most people know it's rubbish but um
donald trump showed you know you can go
on broadcasting rubbish fake news and
sometimes you get away with it not
always okay
my lord we must leave it there but it's
always great to talk to you i'm sure
we'll speak again during the course of
the week thank you thank you thank you
uh more on the crisis now and while most
airlines have stopped flying over
ukraine air baltic have actually put on
extra flights to kiev let's find out why
should we martin garcia's their ceo
hello thank you for joining us on the
programme
what do you know that the other airlines
don't
when there was the request from a couple
of governments that their citizens
should leave immediately we had a much
higher demand so we added flights last
week
these were the extra flights but we are
flying our regular flights up to two
times a day to kiev
and also we fly to vilnius and odessa
and we're evaluating the situation of
course as everybody else
but currently there is no restriction
for us to fly
and therefore we continue serving the
ukraine and what do you how what
criteria do you use to assess risk
the same criteria everybody else uses
that baltic was actually the first
airline stopping to fly to bella russian
airspace and we caused i guess
later on the restrictions there because
we decided that is not safe anymore so
the same criteria all the international
services and then we decide to stop if
we consider it not safe anymore what
would need to change for you to decide
that you don't want to fly in kiev air
space or ukrainian airspace anymore
any restriction of the airspace any
advice from any authority that the
airspace is not safe then we would stop
immediately and as we're very close to
that airspace we are we can contact our
aircraft what we have done as a
precaution all of our aircraft are
taking the fuel to return and we could
return even in the air so we we do this
all the time as we are flying to a lot
of destinations and we've done that with
bella russia as the first airline we
would do it also here if it's needed
what's your advice to passengers who are
anxious about flying over ukrainian
airspace
we see currently a demand from both ends
so there's passengers flying to the
ukraine and and out of the ukraine and
of course somebody who does not want to
travel should not travel but we are
providing a connectivity uh not only uh
to latvia and lithuania we also then
have connecting flights and there's a
lot of
people who want to fly in and out and as
long as that is safe we continue to do
so
okay
what impact is all of this uncertainty
having on the airline
of course what is never good is any
conflict and we are already
circumnavigating the belarussian
airspace and
all these restrictions of course are not
good we're just coming out of a pandemic
as airline industry and we would of
course wish that the negotiation or the
discussions map which might happen this
week lead to a de-escalation
for our industry it's never good to have
any conflict in the world
good to talk to you thank you so much
for taking the time to join us thank you
just hearing
within the last few seconds from the
kremlin they're telling us that
president putin and president macron
have agreed there is need to continue
dialogue on ukraine we know that the two
leaders spoke for an hour and 45 minutes
on the telephone yesterday this was
their meeting in moscow a couple of
weeks ago they have certainly been
chatting quite a lot over the last
couple of weeks or so as has the german
chancellor uh chancellor schultz he's
also been
to moscow i was concerned that it looks
as though an invasion was very much uh
on the cards some suggesting it even had
already started but this is the latest
from the kremlin by the reuters news
agency saying that the kremlin has
saying uh that president putin and
president macron have agreed there is a
need to continue dialogue on the ukraine
i mean anywhere you look at that it is
uh positive news at this stage um
they spoke we're hearing uh from uh the
tass news agency that president putin
and president macron sport spoke on the
phone for a second time twice on sunday